avec ça dit bonjour bonjour bonjour
voila alexa est très poli comment est ce
que vous allez aujourd'hui on est là
pour parler de cette petite chose là
cette grosse grâce à de belles choses là
c'est amazon et côte-chaude disent
regardez c'est beau ça tourne ça fait le
tour quasiment à 360° il ya un petit but
et qui est là et l'amazonie gauche
odyssée un truc est super intéressant
c'est en fait la combinaison entre une
enceinte amazon avec ça et un écran et
cette combinaison les super intéressante
grâce notamment à sept caméras que vous
aviez planck est là et c'est une caméra
de 3 mégapixels qui va faire un vrai
suivi de votre visage alors ça bouge ça
bouge un peu dans tous les sens ça bouge
ça tourne c'est pratique c'est malin je
vais vous montrer je vais vous expliquer
vous allez voir en quoi cet objet là est
super intéressant pour votre maison
connectée
tu va vous prendre pleins de bons
services et tout ça sans les mains
[Musique]
les coaches odyssée ça on dirait une
espèce de cylindres d'enceinte amazon à
l'excellent en fait ici vous avez deux
tweeters pour vous restituer les sons
aigus puis vous avez offert
omnidirectionnelle et à l'avant vous
avez cet écran là un petit écran hd de
10,1 pouces qui combinait grâce à ce que
vous avez ici c'est à dire une petite
caméra de 3 mégapixels qui est planqué
juste ici permet d'avoir un tracking de
votre visage une reconnaissance et la
bouche très facilement si vous souhaitez
orienter l'écran ça par contre il faut
le faire vous directement parce que pas
de moteur inclut sur cet axe là mais
sinon pour le reste ça bouge tout seul
c'est pratique et vous avez également
des boutons sur le dessus ça c'est un
petit cache caméra c'est un vrai petit
cache physique bouton de volume vous
montez vous blesser et là vous venez
tout désactiver le micro et la caméra
donc pour tous des questions de
confidentialité de sécurité gardé vous
faites ça vous fait ça hop on peut plus
vous écouter vous voir pas si vous le
verrez bien me garder
lorsque je me cache caméra ça vient le
bloqués ici pour le coup c'est physique
c'est pratique ça c'est bien voilà
comment ça se passe la caméra revient
vous reconnaitre et elle va se déplacer
en vous suivant vous avez qu'à l'appeler
alexa elle arrive elle me voit elle
vient d'un mois je suis là je suis là je
suis là je suis là tu ne sais pas mais
tu me suis tassé bien elle existe en
deux couleurs vous avez soit
l'anthracite comme ça soit en blanc et
c'est un produit qui coûte 249 euros 99
le son est vraiment bien bonne celle des
graphologues surtout là dessus et
j'avais 3 ans elle les années sont
passées pour amener la très très très
fort c'est vraiment extrêmement fort si
vous le pousser à fond vous pouvez alors
l'idée c'est d'écouter de la musique ça
marchera mais voyez la qualité là ici
vous avez une luminosité des couleurs
adaptatif qui vont venir s'adapter aux
conditions de la pièce dans laquelle
vous êtes si à mon cou lui a pas
beaucoup de lumière sa version adaptée
pour éviter de vous fatiguer les jeux
typiquement et c'est un produit s'il
vous intéresse je vous ai mis un lien en
bas dans la description et bonne
nouvelle est un produit qui est à gagner
là là juste là peut gagner vous aussi
votre éco show 10 pour piloter votre
maison très facilement et profiter tous
les services que vous pouvez avoir avec
pour participer c'est très simple vous
avez un lien en bas dans la description
vous cliquez vous suivez vous allez
petite question et si vous répondez
juste vous serez peut-être tirés au sort
pour gagner vous aussi votre éco show 10
d'une valeur de 249 euros 99 à l'aider
cliquez sur le lien en bas
bonne chance à tous vous pouvez très
bien par exemple demander ici alexa de
vous mettre de la musique
alexa mais les beatles this is beatles
sur spotify alors ici j'ai ajouté mon
compte spotify avec ça arrête la musique
evous ici
problème de droits d'auteur si je mets
d'habitude ça va pas le faire mais vous
pouvez très bien avoir un compte amazon
musique apple musique
spotify deezer vous venez le lier
directement ici à alexa grâce à votre
application alexa sur vos smartphones
c'est extrêmement pratique et ça marche
bien donc ça c'est super mais je ne suis
pas si moi je suis sûr et ça c'est
important
de la même manière vous allez demander
de vous filer un coup de main pour faire
de la cuisine ici je suis dans la
cuisine par exemple avec ça deux mois la
recette de la truffade j'ai une recette
de truffade qui demandent dix minutes de
préparation et qui est notée 3,9 sur
cinq
voulez-vous les ingrédients les avis
lancé la recette ou la recette suivante
lancé la recette pour combien de
personnes souhaitez vous faire cette
recette quatre ingrédients pour 4
personnes vous avez les mains prises par
contre c'est en train de cuisiner lui et
l'intérêt c'est qu'avec la caméra il va
venir vont suivre il va le suivre vos
déplacements ça vous permettra de venir
cuisiner extrêmement facilement sans
venir toucher l'écran à aucun moment et
sans venir salir vous avez des commandes
vocales pour avancer et reculer
demandez le nombre de qr que vous devez
mettre à soupe à café et compagnie danse
est vachement bien
vous pouvez la même manière lui demander
d'ajouter a introduit dans votre liste
de courses alexa ajoute du lait à ma
liste d'achats l'ajouter à votre liste
et d'un chien ghoul
vous devez pouvoir me regarder des films
des séries la télé la télé sur molotov
tv il suffit de connecter vos comptes en
or sera très très facile au avec prague
vidéo bien évidemment avec netflix
également avec ça mais lucifer sur
netflix lucifer est disponible sur
netflix
je sais je regarde la série vous pouvez
par exemple demande et d'allumer la télé
alexa allume la télé et là hop on vient
communiquer avec la télé qui est juste
derrière et ça marche très très bien
alors parce qu en fait derrière je vous
ai installé fire cube d'amazon vous
pouvez venir piloter votre fire cube à
distance à la voix grâce ici à votre et
cochon vous pouvez piloter la maison
connectée directement ici que ce soit
vos ampoules ouverture fermeture des
volets ouverture fermeture des portes
pour ça il faut vous utilisez des
services qui sont compatibles y en a
énormément ici ça s'appelle des ce
qu'ils alexa est allé lumière du salon
pratique la même manière ont pu demander
de gérer pièce par pièce indépendamment
j'ai associé mon compte philips ue avec
mon compte amazon alexa et ça marche
très bien et vous pouvez venir piloter
votre maison connectée ici voyez par
exemple l'âge et le salon monte baissé
activer désactiver comme je veux les
lumières donc ça c'est très très
pratique et de la même manière ici je
retrouve ma maison connectée avec mes
différents appareils que je peux venir
allume et éteint très facilement en tout
cas c'est sympa aussi je veux dire
passer des appels entre mes différents
appareils là par exemple j'ai
l'application sur mon smartphone se
passer un petit coup de fil ici avec
drop in je clique hop là j'appuie ici je
sélectionne mont écho show là je vois je
suis en train d'appeler ouais il veut
bien parler ils cliquent sur répond
voilà alors là je suis trop précieux en
écho et toi qui est vachement sympa
lorsque vous venez passer un coup de fil
c'est qu'en fait il suit la voyez c'est
vraiment tout le suivi du visage par
exemple je viens par la pop là il me
suit il me suit il me suit il me suit et
il vient directement là pour être face à
moi et pour venir me voir
imaginez que j'ai les mains prises par
exemple et lui il va venir me suivre
directement venir inverser la vue donc
là je me mets en grand c'est tout le
cadre au niveau de mon visage il
reconnaît mon visage ici où est ce que
je vais aller
il sait comment je bouge et il vient
d'afficher directement donc ça c'est
vraiment extrêmement pratique c'est
exactement ce système que vous avez
lorsque vous êtes en train de cuisiner
que vous avez les mains prises lorsqu'il
vous suit c'est ce trac qui il connaît
votre visage il reconnaît votre visage
et il vient vous suivre la extrêmement
facilement donc ça c'est très très très
très pratique et ça vient même soumet un
peu voyez il ya l'effet de zoom de des
zooms si je monte un peu normalement bah
il vient un peu il vient me suivre sur
le au point qu'il tout bête mais qui est
vachement sympa c'est que ça vous fait
un cadre photo ici j'ai laissé les
photos un peu classique pour pas
afficher toute ma vie privée mais si
vous voulez afficher toutes vos photos
extrêmement facilement bien vous venez
directement le faire depuis
l'application alexa vous paramétrez çà
et là vous avez les photos que vous
voulez qu'ils viennent s'afficher et
aprilia différentes petites applications
notamment une application quiz qui est
sympa alexa mais un quiz musical
voilà voilà ça c'est rigolo c'est un
petit trou et je peut me répondre alexa
arrête le quiz ciao donc ce qu'ils
veulent mais en pratique c'est que voyez
il ya des plaintes de choses hyper
interactive vous pouvez lui poser les
questions
le demander de raconter une blague enfin
bref quoi tout ce qu'on peut venir faire
ici avec un masque d'alexa vous pouvez
le faire mais en plus ici avec un écran
avec un écran qui vous suit et ça c'est
l'écossé qui est extrêmement pratique et
vous pouvez également surveiller votre
maison à distance grâce à votre
application votre application sur votre
smartphone va venir se connecter
directement à votre éco choisissent et
voulait voir venir naviguer grâce à la
caméra vous balader
à 360 degrés vous avez accès à votre
météo vous avez accès à votre calendrier
à votre liste de tâches vous pouvez
créer des rappels des routines routine
matinale d'hier allumer la lumière
ouvrir les volets compagnie également
une routine de soi vous dit le mot
magique ça vous dit bonne nuit et elle
va venir fermer les volets fermé la
porte à clef couper les lumières et vous
n'êtes plus qu'à vous endormez en toute
sécurité voilà donc pour l'amazone et
cochaux 10 un écran une enceinte de
l'intelligence amazon derrière beaucoup
de services une caméra est l objet qui
suivent le mouvement
j'aime beaucoup l'idée de cet objet pour
la maison connectée que vous posez un
endroit dans le dos peuvent vraiment
venir pivoter pour pouvoir communiquer
très facilement sans les mains avec ses
proches pour pouvoir suivre une recette
pour pouvoir ajouter des produits à sa
liste de courses pouvoir commander très
facilement passer un production assez
complet que je trouve vraiment
intéressant qui a un écran que bonne
qualité on pourrait vouloir aller au
plus loin au niveau de l'écran c'est un
écran d'appoint c'est pas ici un écran
qui vous servira regarder pendant des
heures des films et des séries
non c'est pas l'objet mais c'est un
écran de contrôle qui vous servira dans
plein d' usage différent que ce soit
super bien et il faut vraiment dire
souligné si la qualité audio qui est
vraiment aussi très très bonne 250 euros
un tout petit peu moins de 250 euros
c'est un produit je vous recommande s'il
vous intéresse si vous êtes dans
l'univers d'amazon si vous cherchez une
enceinte connecter pour la maison j'aime
beaucoup cette idée là est pour moi la
grosse valeur ajoutée c'est vraiment ça
c'est vraiment l'objet qui bouge c'est
le tracking
c'est ce suivi l'accueillir désactiver
quand vous le souhaitez si vous ne
souhaitez pas être regardé pas être
écoutés vous avez les boutons physiques
donc ça c'est vachement bien aussi en
termes de confidentialité a vous de me
dire ce que vous en pensez en bas juste
en bas en commentaire comment vous
trouvez ce produit écran sainte
connecter sans les mains vous pour le
résumer comme ça c'est l'amazonie
cochaux 10 à vous de me dire ce que vous
en pensez en bas sur ceux des bisounours
patrick châteaux